(music)
I'm Mike McGehee and I'm a professor in
Material Science and Engineering at
Stanford University. And I'm the Academic
Director of the Energy Innovation and
Emerging Technologies program. We created
the program because there's a huge need
to transform the way we generate, store
and use energy, ah, to meet the world's
energy needs and prevent, ah, climate change.
The curriculum in the program takes a
holistic view of energy. We have a broad
collection of courses that covers the
whole energy sector. People can choose
to take some of the more engineering oriented courses, or
they can take courses that look at the
bigger picture-
economical aspects and the social aspects. It's
incredibly valuable
to be learning from people who are right at the cutting edge.
Many of the best professors in the world who do
research on energy are here at Stanford
and for each of the topics we were able to
get world-class scholars. It's great to
be able to take these Stanford courses from anywhere in the
world at any time.
It's incredibly convenient. People who take
these courses will understand what the
technology can do today, and they'll get
a pretty good idea of what might be able to do
in five years, ten years, twenty-five years.
They'll see the competing technologies
and the advantages and disadvantages of those.
Energy is so important for nearly everything we do.
This program will help people understand
where the energy industry is headed.
(music to fade out)